[Music]
in case all of you in the good old US of
A have missed the turkeys running around
for dear life this week tomorrow is
Thanksgiving without even a close second
Thanksgiving is by far my favorite
holiday of the year
I find that focusing on the three EPs
family friends and food usually brings
out the best in just about everybody
between the tryptophan from the turkey
your booze of choice and football in the
background all of us at least in my
experience are just a little bit better
on this day which we've set aside to
give thanks for all the goodness in our
lives
Thanksgiving is the ultimate reminder of
what it means to be American while most
of us have the usual staples of turkey
mashed potatoes stuffing and cranberry
sauce around the table we also bring in
traditions from our own cultures
ethnicities and nationalities this
blending of flavors languages and
customs from all over the world is what
makes Thanksgiving a uniquely American
holiday no offense to Canadian
Thanksgiving the melting pot that we've
created here has given more freedom to
more people from more walks of life than
any other country in the history of the
world today people still yearn to come
to America to take part in our freedom
and pretty much nobody wants to leave
America no matter how often celebrities
say that they will this doesn't mean
we're perfect or anywhere close to it
but it does mean that our tradition of
freedom based on and rooted in the
pursuit of life liberty and happiness is
a pretty good starting point for how to
build a truly liberal and tolerant
society while politics will undoubtably
be discussed around the Thanksgiving
table this year I'm gonna do my best to
try to viewer the conversation always to
what brings us together rather than what
rips us apart maybe your uncle is
pro-life and you're pro-choice maybe
your sister voted for Hillary but you
voted for Trump maybe you want low taxes
and your dad wants to redistribute
wealth whatever those differences are
they are actually the very reason that
this country is so great we all get to
have our own opinion and fight for what
we believe
Eve but beyond just the ability to be
tolerant of people who are different
from us it's more important that we can
still learn from live with and even love
people who think differently than we do
I hope you have a wonderful day tomorrow
filled with those 3 FS I mentioned
earlier friends family and food and
maybe one more F if you get lucky either
way let's give thanks tomorrow for all
the goodness we have but often forget to
even acknowledge Happy Thanksgiving to
you
and all your loved ones joining me today
is the creator of the Dilbert comic
strip author of the new book win big Lea
and a guy who seems to make some pretty
spot-on predictions scott adams welcome
back to the Reuben report thanks for
having me
before we begin I got to tell you I was
looking at these blurbs on the back of
this book how did you get these people
William Shakespeare
Mark Twain Alexander the Great Abe
Lincoln and even the Scott Adams guy I
mean how in the world did you pull this
off I stick with dead people because
they can't complain later
it's like not one of them has complained
that I've misquoted him you know Mark
Twain he said nothing about this quote
so what I saw this I thought immediately
there must be an estate for some of
these people that monitor these types of
things do you even have to think about
that does the editor or the publisher go
Scott you can't Wayne come on well
luckily my job is parody yeah and so so
I know those laws pretty well okay as
long as it's obvious parody you can do
anything you want yeah so we checked
right before you walked in we had you on
the show September 1st of 2016 about two
months before the election and when I
had you on you were one of the only
people that I thought basically was
making sense of what was going on with
Trump at the time you you didn't say you
were a trump supporter I think you
actually said you were not a trump
supporter you had sort of said the thing
about your you know in a hostage
situation with Hillary but you know
basically you were saying here's what
Trump is doing I I don't necessarily
support it I think you by the election
time you officially did support him
right
yeah the because of one issue basically
when when Clinton came out with the
a state tax plan and I realized that I
personally would pay roughly 75 cents on
every dollar I would earn for the rest
of my life which would basically make me
retire
yeah I wouldn't possibly work for that
so that that changed my mind yeah I
wasn't gonna jump into the estate tax
but I do find it one of the interesting
things I don't stand to make a windfall
from the estate tax but I find it one of
those things where it's like this money
has been taxed for someone's entire life
your money that you earn through all
your hard work has been taxed your whole
life hopefully you've made good
investments and whatever else you've
done I met at the end the government
just says okay we're gonna just
basically take more than half of it at
that point after we've already taken it
the whole time the whole tax thing
there's no way to make it fair because
there's always somebody who's gonna
complain but some things just feel less
fair and that feels more like
confiscation than tax yeah but I guess
it's easy to be one of those people that
just are like well I'm not involved in
this I don't stand to win anything of it
so why wouldn't I want to take the money
from other people right yeah yeah that's
the big problem with a democratic system
people can vote vote other people's
money into their pocket if there are
enough of a motive yeah all right so
it's a little over a year ago
that we had you on you're making some
sense of the techniques that are that
you're writing about in this book about
persuasion and what Trump is doing and
all that around that time just like two
months before the election did you
really think it was real I did really
believe that he was going to win those
weeks that we're talking about and most
of the time up to them the only time my
confidence was really shaken was at the
same time everybody else was you know
after the Access Hollywood [ __ ] was a
gay thing got dropped I don't think
anybody thought that day that he could
get out of that I haven't heard of one
person who said yeah that didn't bother
me at all but it was just amazing there
was so much news that that whole cycle
and so much more came after that that
even something that large didn't have
the impact it would have had because it
got lost and you know the the the
enormity of it all yeah what does that
tell you generally about truth right now
now the subtitle of your book is
persuasion in a world where facts
don't matter facts and truth have a
little something to do with each other
what does that actually tell you that
something like that could happen
regardless of whether you think it was
just something he said or locker room
talk or all that nonsense but that
things don't stick in a way yeah they
used to let me give some context for
people or new to me yeah in addition to
cartooning and writing and stuff I'm a
trained hypnotist yeah and I've been
studying persuasion in all its forms for
four decades so I was looking through
that filter and one of the things that
hypnotist learned is that people are
irrational pretty much all the time and
they just rationalize their decisions
and believe that it made sense all along
and that's the normal way of things
until you get in that mindset the whole
world looks confusing you can't
understand why you gave your good
reasons and your facts and your logic
and and the person you're talking to
didn't change their mind
so my view on the election was that our
certainly by the time that the excess
Hollywood tape dropped probably almost
every mind was made up they didn't know
why but they had made up their minds for
emotional irrational whatever reasons so
it's tough to dislodge somebody you know
he would have had to murder somebody in
public to change minds at that point
that late stage because people are
really hardened in their opinions by
then yeah what does that tell you I mean
as we're taping this this will be up
next week so a little right before
Thanksgiving we're taping this me
today's the 8th yesterday they done
right okay that sounds you're good
you're a pro what does that tell you as
I'm watching all these people on Twitter
in the last day or so with this Thank
You Hillary hashtag and all this stuff
and this continued worship of her even
though by every estimation she probably
was the worst candidate in the history
of American politics pot that might be a
bit of an overblown statement but what
is it what does that day that they're
still on this they're still on this
thing that but Rumble but consider that
statement we consider it now a given
that she was one of the worst candidates
we've ever seen prior to the election
and really maybe up right up until
election day the general thought on both
sides was this is one of the strongest
candidates we've ever seen for
everything from funding to experience to
it was
time for a for a woman people were you
know emotionally in every other way the
world was ready for that so it's only
after the fact that we've now
reinterpreted what we saw as well she
was the worst candidate ever and I don't
know if either one of those is true I
think we had two candidates who had some
real big pluses she had lots of pluses
and some real big flaws in both cases
yeah do you think that basically Trump
from before the elections oh so during
the process until now after a year of
governing basicly or ten months or so of
governing has basically used this book I
know he didn't have it but you know what
I mean like has he is this really what
he has done from beat one that you saw
before a lot of people did so you have
to understand his entire life arc starts
with going to a church where his pastor
was norman vincent peale the famous
author who wrote the power of positive
thinking and so that's that's the first
place you probably learned persuasion at
least one corner of persuasion because
in his time norman vincent peale was
actually accused the big a hypnotist he
was that influential so that optimism
you see him using it all the time to
make us think into the future when he
talks about the GDP he doesn't say well
we got 3% that's pretty good that's what
a normal president would say he says
we've got 3% but without the hurricanes
I think it would have been four we'll
probably got 4% I think we'll do better
than that he's actually talking us into
the future and if you if you consider
how an economy works unless you have
shortages of stuff and we're really you
know in a great time because we don't
have shortages of anything it's
psychology that drives it so if people
think we're heading to 4% they're gonna
invest a little bit more this year to
get ready for that and that's what makes
it 4% he's actually taking what he
learned as a child and you know that
that persuasive thinking into the future
and driving the economy that way and
then if you look at his full full range
of he you know sort of cell marketing
branding nobody doubts any of those
skills at this point and then
negotiating he wrote literally you know
authored with a co-author a book on
negotiating so
Sene persuasion from every every angle
including design you know he is the one
who I believe came up with or at least
approved the the hats and make America
great again and and I think people will
look back at this for four years and say
that was the best branding we've ever
seen yeah it's interesting to me because
you said the the positive way he speaks
and then you gave some examples but if
you listen to the just the general
narrative out there this is the most
divisive president all the time he says
all these horrible things what do you
make of that portion of him the the
Twitter portion that's fighting with
people still all the time doing things
that in my opinion are below the office
of the presidency and I say that as
someone that that I really did the
reason I wasn't surprised when Trump won
was because I actually sat down with you
right before and I listened and I
started seeing this stuff so I wasn't
thoroughly I was on Brogan Joe Rogan the
day before the election or maybe it was
election day actually and I was like
yeah I think it's possible and did I
actually change your mind on that well I
don't know that you I don't know that
you fully changed my mind but you made
me aware of what was happening I think
basically before I sat down with you I
was sort of where I think a lot of
people still are which is they're just
grabbing for anything you know what I
mean like they're just they have nothing
that they're really basing any decisions
on they see the tweets they scream about
the tweets or they don't even have a
chance to scream about the tweets
because the media gets outraged before
they can even process it and and you
sort of framed it in a way that's
basically said to me there's something
sensible about this yeah what I think
most people have kind of missed that one
of the things that is deeply important
for a persuasion is first you have to
get people's attention that's like you
know phase one at this point can can
anybody argue that he's the best we've
ever seen at getting attention all right
let's think that one even his biggest
haters might say yeah like the way he
has dominated the media and every
conversation yes
so step walk and get attention and the
way he does that because he he operates
in what I call a narrow band of
wrongness meaning that if this is
appropriate behavior he just takes it up
to this band you know with the nicknames
and the the provocative things he says
but he never goes up here where you'd
get impeached
be put in the insane asylum and start a
nuclear war if you look how long he's
been doing this and how how consistently
he stays in that narrow band of
wrongness which is persuasion perfection
because you can't look away and then
you're thinking about why he wants you
to think about now consider also that
he's also been meeting with a lot of
world leaders at this point he doesn't
do that in that context so it's clear
that he can modify his behavior to get
the effect he needs we didn't know that
for sure I'll say other people didn't
know that for sure you know when he was
running it looked a little crazy and
maybe out of control but now we've seen
the fine control he puts on it you know
on Twitter that narrowbanded wrongness
every time in real life he can modulate
everything being equal as a smart guy
and a bright guy and an author and
someone that cares about words and all
of those things putting Trump aside for
a moment would you prefer that we just
had a president that was a little more
within the common standards of decency
or seemed to really appreciate you know
I keep telling the story that I was in
DC a couple weeks ago and I went to all
the monuments I was reading all the
great things that Jefferson wrote and
George Washington all like it's very
different then when they look back and
they put Trump's tweets next to all of
it well I have I have mixed feelings for
one a lot one of the things that the
people on the left let's say the the
anti-trump errs whoever they are don't
get is how entertaining he is to his
base the people who actually like what
he's got to offer find it amazingly
entertaining and funny so the things
that people are saying oh I can't
believe he said that he's he's an
affront to all civilization that's why
it's funny it's funny because we know he
does it intentionally and we know the
effect it'll have on us or a group of
people and that's sort of the joke that
it has that effect now to answer your
question we were never offered somebody
who had his his talents and his specific
policies that appealed to a lot of
people who voted for him without the
flaws you know nobody offered the you
know the Trump without the tweets that
make people angry and I would argue that
probably 80% of the things that feel
like they're over the live actually are
functional and the 20% then there's you
know how do you mean functional gets
attention it puts a nickname on somebody
that actually takes them completely out
of the primaries we saw that with Low
Energy jab and I think the crooked
Hillary thing was was quite effective
but there are other things that are
maybe just too far you know a little
they don't have they're not so far I get
some peach but they're you know not
useful but they also don't seem to hurt
him in the long run we've seen something
we may never see again which is a
complete disconnect between approval
ratings which are terrible mm-hmm and
people's image of what the economy is
doing for example business confidence is
great yeah yeah I don't think we'll ever
see those disconnect again and it's
because of his style does that also show
you that people just don't care about
polls anymore I mean I saw a poll on
Sunday on CNN and it said you know half
of Americans don't trust Trump and I
thought well half Americans don't trust
CNN I mean that all of the nut you know
you mean it's like you guys threw all
these numbers at us before you through
all this nonsense at us before and now
you're still throwing nonsense and I
don't try I really almost trust none of
it and I it makes it harder to siphon
some truth out and now the onus is on I
was just saying a poll that was saying
that something about what people think
the leaders think of the president and
I'm thinking how do we know what leaders
in other countries think of the
president what what good is that poll
right oh yeah we're a little why is that
even relevant in an odd way you know so
if they fear us certain countries we
want them to fear us so they probably
won't like the president whether it was
Trump or Obama or anyone else well I've
been saying from the beginning one of
the big things has scared people about a
president Trump was that how our other
leader is going to deal with this guy
you know is are they going to be
frightened will they make them you know
the nucleus just in case no problem so
far it turns out that if you're the
President of the United States and you
have good table manners when you when
you talk to other leaders there's
there's nothing that they would rather
do than deal with you because it's in
their best interest and it works so I
listen to you
on Sam Harris's podcast and Sam
obviously been here a bunch of times I
find him to be one of the brightest and
most thoughtful people that I know you
guys obviously differ greatly on the on
the Trump thing probably more than
anything else but when you hear him make
a couple of those arguments
whichever one you can pick any one does
any of it get to you does any of it you
know the the moral Center just what the
what's really going on if things really
escalated with North Korea you can pick
one out of the bag well for those who
didn't hear my conversation with Sam on
his podcast I was not addressing the
moral ethical dimension because I
figured people are on their own for that
in other words my moral Center is not
much different than everybody else's I
have exactly the same preferences if you
could do things without lying without
insulting people
of course I prefer that but nobody gave
us that choice you know we didn't get
that candidate we had to leave the
choices that we had so I think there was
there's an illusion that Sam and I
disagreed on the ethical moral stuff I
simply take the position fair yeah right
because it really wasn't addressed
specifically asked I don't think I take
the position that if if if a terrorist
was holding your child and the only way
I could save him is lying to the
terrorists I will lie to the terrorists
to save your child now if you wouldn't
I'm not sure that you can claim a moral
high ground there are some situations
such as beating Isis you know having a
good economy these are fantastically
good things for human beings if you had
if the only way you could get there is
bends bend some truths then I'm a little
bit more flexible about that but I don't
think my moral look on this is any
different than anybody else's yeah but
but what about just the concerns that
Sam and others like the people that are
the real critics oh forget forget we can
put Sam aside because I don't know if
people haven't listened to it it's not
important but wouldn't you hear people
say well Trump is so erratic and he's
dealing with an erratic leader in North
Korea and all of those things you you
basically think that that's all just
playing that that other higher bar this
way and that in reality we're still
doing well well we could talk about
North
career separately cuz that's really kind
of it there's nothing like that that's
sort of its own situation and at the
moment I think he's handling that right
well let's talk about that yeah let's do
it what do you think about North Korea
so for however many decades we haven't
really had any progress because we they
promise things and then they don't do
them this is probably the first time
that little rocket man shall we call him
is literally worried that he'll be dead
in the next thirty days
I don't think they've ever had that
thought before and that's gotta help in
the negotiations now if you're thinking
but that might make him you know fire
off a nuke well that's the only way you
could be sure your dad so right now his
only two choices are dead for sure and I
don't think he wants to make that or
worrying about being dead unless he
comes to the negotiating table and and
there seems to be some maybe a little
bit of a hint of a movement there yeah
but do your big question what about all
the other stuff that that is yeah as
matic yeah if you were to list all the
things that people consider that the
criticisms of Trump on one column and
then all the things that people even as
critics would say okay these things are
going well you would find that the
things that are going well are generally
real meaning that there is less Isis
stocks are up you know we they did he
did appoint justices that leased his
side likes immigration is down by fifty
percent these are real and measurable
things and they matter and they're big
if you look at the list of things that
people are criticizing it's well we
think he might cause a problem mm-hmm
we think this could go wrong we're
concerned that people think about him
this way we think that his supporters
are you know more racist than they are
almost all of them would would be
legitimately classified as imaginary now
that's not to say that there couldn't be
bad things in the future but at the
moment they are purely imagined yeah
it's interesting because I was on Sam's
AMA podcast and we discussed this and I
mentioned or he brought up the interview
with you but that's what I said to
basically I said look I didn't even vote
for the guy I brought on many for the
week before the election I had Hillary
row
he's a progressive operative basically
to come on and talk about why not to
vote for him but then I had people like
you and others on and tried to talk to
everybody about it but ice basically
said that two sandwiches the things that
he's actually been able to do are
basically mainstream Republican things
that if any other Republican would have
done the things that he hasn't been able
to do actually show the strength of our
system because if you don't like the his
health care plan or the taxman or
whatever US Congress is fighting him and
that's the way the government supposed
to work and the other things the tweets
and all the other stuff it's like well
that's just not that's just nothing it's
just stuff you know take health care so
so if you were gonna make a criticism
about the president's performance Health
Care would be at the top of the list of
criticisms and this is this illustrates
what I call the the two movies on one
screen we're all looking at the same set
of facts and and we're producing
completely different movies in our minds
about what's happening so some people
will say well he hasn't solved health
care that's that's a failure but my
observation is what was the deadline for
that but is there a time you're supposed
to be done and that that it that passed
because I don't see the deadline what I
see is somebody who let the Republicans
go first fail hard because they were
going to they didn't have a plan that
was going to be popular scare the left
while letting the the right fail as hard
as they can and then what's he do he
says well maybe I'll talk to the
Democrats until he gets both of them in
this situation setting the table he
calls it he actually has a word for this
right this is not accidental you know if
your brand is negotiating and you do
things that any objective person who
understands negotiating recognizes as
correct technique he's softening up both
sides and it's going to take a while it
might take Obama care to fail a little
harder it might take the public to see
their either their costs going up in
Obama care that's not a good thing but
it might be the only way you can get
these two sides that are on such
opposites somewhere in the middle yeah
so as he failed I would say it's a
process and it's probably the only way
it could go how much are you concerned
at all that the people around him this
is one of the things I hear a lot that
the people around him that for
there's certain things aren't staffed
right now I in her I don't have that
much of a problem with that because I
think the government should be a lot
smaller as a general rule but putting
that aside that people say they will the
intellectual acumen around him isn't
that great like you've got these players
around him these people that understand
a lot of things you're talked about but
not sort of like a serious group of like
intellects around him well in what
department you know does he really need
help in the State Department because the
the international stuff looks like it's
going pretty well does he need help in
the economics seems like it's going
really well does he need more help than
general mattis to beat Isis mattis is
doing great now if you get down to you
know the Department of Agriculture and
you know the EPA and stuff those are
real arguments you can have about
whether you've got the right horsepower
there and and I would I would listen to
those arguments for sure but in terms of
the how much is staffed and whether
there's enough staff I'm still waiting
for that to matter well it sort of goes
to that other point of just the other
things there's some literal things that
have happened and some maybes and
creditors do you ever feel like you're
stuck sort of acting as his counsel
publicly or something
yeah I suddenly felt like I was like
really grilling you on Trump and it was
in an odd way because we're obviously
going to talk about your book too but
it's all intertwined yeah it's funny in
my mind it's always about persuasion and
about a more effective way to see the
world that does a better job but
predicting you know I guess it's now a
year and a half ago I said that he would
do more than change politics and boy has
he changed politics but I said he would
rip a hole in our reality to let us look
through and see something completely
different
and he's done that because didn't you
used to think that facts mattered and
didn't usually think that if somebody
said as many things as he said that the
fact checker said oh no that doesn't
that doesn't work that you couldn't
possibly become president and if you did
you couldn't possibly have a good
economy you beat Isis and all the other
things he's doing none of it was true
and if you were a trained persuader you
could see that early you could see that
none of that would matter because you
can see that his
his persuasive skill was that strong now
I have to jump in to just say one point
yeah
facts do matter to outcomes and all
things being equal we would love to get
the accurate facts but usually when he's
non-factual he's persuading in the
direction that we would like so if he
says the number of deaths by gun in
Chicago or a thousand per day but it's
really 10 per day we still need to fix
that problem and he made us focus on it
the fact that it wasn't accurate did it
matter
it didn't now and I think he knows it
and I think it's conscious and he calls
it a hyperbole he has a name for it yeah
yeah well that was gonna be my follow-up
question do you think he's really
conscious of all of this stuff I would I
guess I would feel better if I really
thought he was conscious of all if I
knew he was conscious about it I guess I
would feel better he's kind yeah that's
the same time that would mean he
intentionally these are lies I mean if
he knows them and he's and he's
intentionally doing it even if it's for
all the reasons that you lay out here in
the book that's still it then it then
it's an outright lie as opposed to just
an exaggeration or hyperbole well I
would say that you have to consider
intention at this point I don't see any
scenario in which the good of the
country and how he does personally are
separated right you know he has to do a
good job for the country so if he's
telling a lie that's good for him and
bad for the country that's just a
frickin lie all right nobody's in favor
of that but if he says hey you know
we've got a you know fight extra hard to
fix this problem that everybody wants
fixed and there's a little bit of an
exaggeration in that well it's still the
direction and we do want to go it's that
it's so you know those situations you
can call it a lie you could call it
someone who didn't pass the
fact-checking
he would call it hyperbole because he's
he's a it's a sort of an exaggerated
truth if you will in other words
directionally it's true just the details
are wrong so as a guy that wrote one of
the most popular has written one of
those popular comic strips of all time
the whole purpose I mean I think of
comic strips and of stand-up ever does
is that you're getting to a kernel of
truth at the end of that
right like every time you I assume is
that is that fair to say that every time
you ever wrote a strip that there's a
kernel of truth at the end right if you
do it right yes if you do it right so
how can you also be the guy that's
saying that it's okay to live in a fax
no matter place like facts and truth
there's that's I don't know up there
right I love that you asked that
question because this is just a perfect
way to make the point the comic strip is
the exaggerated world it's a it's just a
crazy you know something that wouldn't
actually happen in the real world but
what people say about it is that is just
like my job hmm so they're looking at
something that's this crazy world and
they're still seeing the truth and so if
you're a good cartoonist you you've made
both of those things happen they
shouldn't be together
you know and so that's a perfect example
that I get to see every day where people
say that's just like my office and I say
no there were no aliens in your office
you know if somebody's had exploded that
didn't happen in your office you know so
stuff in the comics people we regard as
feeling real when they clearly are not
that's interesting are you familiar with
the term K fab the it's the term that
wrestlers use that you know that's the
fakery that you know everyone knows it's
fake we all know it's fake we're and yet
you're you're eliciting real emotions
from people that go there and pay you to
do something fake and have a real
emotion and I think there is some
connection with that and and what you're
talking about in the Trump was kind of
you know he was a fan of wrestling he's
there's those clips of him I think at
WrestleMania and taken out Vince McMahon
and the rest of it he is playing that
game he has merged theater and politics
like nobody's ever done and that he just
happens to be good at the theater stuff
and so he effectively merged them I
don't think we'll ever see this again
the this is a very special situation and
he has I've probably said this before
but he has a talent stack of individual
talents that he's a b-plus a minus at
but there's so many of them and they
work so well together all of his
persuasion stuff is his theater stuff is
public speaking is you know his
intelligence they're all they're all
high but you'd say to yourself wow
had smarter presidents we've had better
orators orators orators okay people who
speak better than I do even right yeah
one way or another we Natalie have those
yeah but very few people have had that
combination with business experience
with with his ability to take criticism
even though people say he's thin-skinned
you don't get into this game unless you
you know you can handle the criticism do
you think Trump derangement syndrome is
a real mental disorder I'm starting to
actually I mean I'm being slightly
facetious here but I'm actually starting
to the signal that it's a real
psychological condition yeah because I
get into these conversations all the
time with you know fans and friends and
family and whatever it is and I just try
I try my hardest to take the most
rational decent approach and what
actually has happened how is you may not
like Gorsuch but that was just a
mainstream can you know that any
mainstream Republican would have put
this guy in now you may be a Democrat
and that's upsetting to you but it's not
it's not Hitler it's not Hitler and so
I've really tried to like take some of
the fangs out of these arguments yeah
but I do find the level that people are
obsessed with this stuff you know in all
seriousness this is a legitimate fairly
major mental health issue and you you
hear psychologists are actually dealing
with people who are coming in and crying
and thinking that the world has exploded
and there's a there's actually a good
reason for it so if you look at the
result it was a surprise to half of the
country so the people who were Trump
supporters even if they were sure he was
going to win what they got was a world
that made sense to them they thought all
along he should win and then when he did
even though it was surprising in the
polls their world was intact everything
that they thought about the world seemed
to be about right and they just thought
other people were wrong but if you were
on the side that knew he couldn't win
there's no way you were living in the
country that this monster could possibly
become our leader and then he woke up
and he was you that's a classic setup
for cognitive dissonance it's where you
have to rewrite the script in your head
to make sense of this new information
and here's what people don't do because
we're all
so let me make this not a comment about
just half the country it's a universal
comment
we rarely rewrite the script in their
head to say you know the best way to
explain this is that I was a [ __ ]
idiot
alright nobody does that right and and
there's nothing wrong with that that's
normal we I don't do it you don't do it
nobody does that so they have to come up
with a new script that explains their
situation and so I think they've come up
with my god there are more racists in
the country than we knew they voted this
guy in and he must have he must have had
help from Russia cuz there's no way this
happens in a natural way because my
world wouldn't make sense if he could
get elected just by having policies
people like couldn't happen so in that
situation these people are I hate to use
trigger but it's it's a specific use of
cognitive dissonance their world doesn't
make sense and they're trying to make
sense of it and it is an emotionally
painful experience which I have genuine
sympathy for yeah so as a guy that you
know deals in persuasion for people that
are watching this that are dealing with
because I get emails every day from
people I can't my brother won't talk to
me my cousin won't talk my wife won't
talk to me I've got emails from people
that have been divorces over politics
yeah what techniques would you tell
someone to do if their spouse was
suffering from this condition well let
me let me tell you I was strong this is
I had postulated over the summer before
the election there when Clinton's
persuasion game went from very weak to
not existent to suddenly just
weapons-grade and when she started
calling everything that Trump did dark
mm-hmm that's the work of a real expert
and I have some speculation about who
there was but for our purposes today
just say it was super good persuasion
that was not like anything she'd done
before and that captured the thought
that he's he's a monster he's our racist
a xenophobe everything he wanted to put
in that that one word captured had
Clinton won the bomb would have been
defused because her side was said oh
yeah we got what we wanted we avoided
the monster the Trump people would have
said oh darn we lost
it wouldn't you know thrown them for so
much of a loop but because it wouldn't
have thrown them for loop where they
sort of would have been used to losing
so it would have it would have been
consistent with the polls they wouldn't
like it but they wouldn't be thrown into
cognitive dissonance okay cause of it
right now it would have seemed like a
normal world but this this thought that
there was this this monster under the
bed people lived with that as a real
thing for months and then when it didn't
go away they had to continue living with
it so that was a setup
so to answer your question how do you
get out of it like how do you cure it I
had predicted way back before
inauguration day that we would see the
following cycle or were story arc if you
will that on inauguration day it would
be Hitler Hitler Hitler you know marches
in the street and we saw that and I said
that after several months of him not
doing Hitler things people would say all
right well it's not as bad as we thought
he's not a Hitler but he's incompetent
and there's chaos and he's just not
going to do things right and maybe
that's just as dangerous so that was the
summer remember I this was all forecast
by me way ahead of time because you
could see that this would have to happen
right and then then I've predicted that
by the end of the year and we're getting
close people would start to say well he
did get a lot of things done so maybe
he's effective but we don't like what
he's done maybe it's not the justices
they wanted and the policies they wanted
but that that part's just politics right
we can all deal with that part right
well well well the only way you're going
to get rid of the the illusion that he's
a monster is by him doing non monster
stuff long enough that you just can't
hold the illusion anymore and I think
that the what's coming and this is the
fun part and this is really the basis
for the prediction is that every year at
the end of the year the news
organizations they sort of run out of
real news and they do the the year-end
roundups right and they're gonna have to
say what did he do and that list is
gonna be really long and this could be
all the stuff you cared about - health
care I think I'm not even sure taxes
will happen but the economy is so strong
I'm not even sure it's important anymore
right what could I get 4% with
without a tax change maybe there'll be
something with business taxes but at
this point I think the list of things
that he's done that Republicans wanted
is going to be so long it would just be
hard for people to hold in their heads
that he wasn't effective and by next
year if we get something with health
care maybe something with taxes it's
gonna look like hard to hold the the
illusion anymore where do you think the
media fits in all of this now because I
think that you can very easily chalk up
their ineptitude an obvious cheering at
first for Bernie but then ultimately for
Hillary you can chalk that up to why so
many of the Trump people and I include
myself in this that I'm thrilled the way
the media is crumbling I think it's a
phenomenal I just this week this past
week there was this idiotic thing with
Trump in Japan you saw this with the
Prime Minister of Japan and CNN tweets
the video out and said you know implying
that he's being disrespectful by dumping
the fish food in the in the koi pond or
whatever what they don't show you is
literally the second before that that's
exactly what the Japanese Prime Minister
day right how do they keep doing this I
mean I cannot chalk this up to complete
idiocy and ineptitude anymore how do
they keep how have they not fired
I mean CNN every day should be just
firing people the wrong they should be
throwing them off the roof of the Time
Warner Center well unfortunately the the
economics of the the news business has
changed you know used to be you have the
three big networks and they could just
deal with the facts as they knew them
but now I don't think you could make
money that way because people are
looking to feel to to digest the news
that they like it makes them feel good
so you're always going to have a you
know media on the right and media on the
left and I don't think that middle may
never be filled because there's no way
to make money in the middle because if
you go in the middle both sides will say
well half the time you're just making
stuff up interestingly I think the
middle whatever that middle is I think
it does sort of exist in this space the
space that you're even though you're not
a creator on YouTube or whatever it kind
of exists in this land of Rogan and
DeFranco and
whoever whatever that influence is I
think sort of exists at the risk of
complement that you don't show you might
be the closest thing and the only thing
I can think of that's in the middle
right now like easily identifiable as as
a legitimate attempt to be in the middle
you know other people have their spin on
things right yeah well I don't even see
others trying out one compliment per
year on the show of me so that was
that's it I was waiting for someone to
do it already in November you know yeah
so yeah and look you had to go outside
the TV model to even make this work but
okay so you are thrilled with the way
the media is being destroyed right I
mean is there any piece of you that
misses that we get our news from three
places and can make some factual sense
together in any of that I know you know
I don't find any joy in that because
it's just something that's broken I
can't get happy about that so I'm not
happy about anybody's destruction but I
understand your point that it feels like
it feels like if people are not doing
their job you want bad things to happen
to him but I can't quite get in that
mindset all right I don't mean like I
don't want to be hurt or anything like
that of course but just the general the
state of this nonsense that's why when
people say to me about what Trump lies
about this all the time well Hillary
lied about this all the time Obama lied
about if you like your doctor you can
keep them and the Syria red line it's
just like well all of them lie and they
used to they just all lied the same way
they lied in a politician's way he lies
in a new way I don't particularly like
either one of them but but there's a
little bit of realpolitik here and I
think that's where you sort of operate
and just sort of there's there's reality
and then there's politics and they have
a little bit overlay sometimes the only
way I could stake out a position that
wasn't one of the crazy on the right or
crazy on the left is by the persuasion
filter it was sort of a step back from
politics per se and and that gave me a
little bit of ability to be as objective
as I can and right nobody's completely
objective but I just don't think that
middle will be where you make all the
money yeah I mean you're you're you're
kind of alone here
yeah well I'm not making Dilbert money
yeah
should be working on a comic strip that
would be your major advice right yes I
tell everybody to start a comic start a
comic strip that that's quit your job
right now yeah do you think it's kind of
funny that you end up talking about
politics so directly because obviously
oh yeah before we mentioned it I mean
you were always sort of giving people a
grain of truth more about their life and
sort of the working world and all of
that but it was more social commentary
but but this is a lot of politics now
you know it's way closer than you think
because since since the things I talk
about are the I would say the illusions
that we have you know in the comic I
would write about the illusion that this
this three-hour meeting was better than
the two-hour meeting that was just an
illusion
yet people buy into it it's you know
widespread practice and and I just took
that you know that same mindset which is
you understand that this isn't real
these things you're doing in the office
these things don't help these don't make
sense this new business policy just
sounds good on paper completely doesn't
work it's really just the same analysis
I just took it to a different field yeah
I'm curious has there been some kind of
cost professionally or personally for
you on this oh yeah I think you I [ __ ]
to quote you I pretty sure you said that
you do have [ __ ] you money I think
that's what you said to me last time so
you may not care yeah but I'm curious
what the cost has been so I think I've
lost 75% of my friends I mean do you
mean that literally like I mean that
literally I mean I don't know if you
were just taking out a Trump position
and then you were gonna scale it back
the 20% I mean I haven't actually done
the calculation but but it feels like
but really yeah I would say that's Joey
I look at my facebook feed and it's just
I just literally thought Facebook wasn't
working for a while and that's not even
look it's not work well it must be some
kind of major problem with Facebook I'm
not I'm not seeing anything from all my
friends here and then financially a big
part of an author's income is speaking
yeah and I can say this now know that
now that I have no speaking engagements
lined up anytime in the future and have
not for the past year well I was making
anywhere from fifty to a hundred
thousand dollars just to talk for an
hour
wow that went to zero meaning I have
nothing booked in the past year and
nothing booked for the future and that's
never happened anytime in my
professional career after the first you
know five years when Dilbert became you
know well-known yeah I find that
particularly bizarre because a you're
you're not a hateful person or any of
the things that people might say about
you but be the things that you're
talking about generally have come true
so the worth of having you speak they're
still worth than having you speak but I
get it's like well we're not gonna pay a
trump supporter yeah that's that's all
this and really even the people who are
making the decisions you know they
understand the nuance and you know if
you tell them well that's not it's not
about the policies they get that but
their job is to make sure there's a big
room full of people who don't feel bad
yeah so they're not going to take a
chance that the people in the room will
have a different interpretation right
that's interesting was it mostly like
corporate type gigs I think it was
almost entirely corporate and big
organizations yeah so that that also
shows you another symptom of what's
happening in the world right now right
that that's someone who basically is
just a moderate decent guy who's saying
some things and maybe is is a supporter
of a guy that's not popular in the
popular sense of the word you know a
corporation just does want to put their
butt on the line yeah and but let me let
me state that as you said I'm not going
to be poor like that that isn't going to
happen
and I knew what I was getting into
alright so you know you and I were
professionals and so people watching
might say oh that poor guy you walked
into the buzzsaw we see the buzzsaw we
choose to walk into it because there's a
there's a bigger something there in this
case this was this weird special case
where people's entire worldview was
going to change I knew that when I saw
Trump enter because he had that kind of
effect and I I thought it would be
helpful to be sort of a guide to help
people understand what they were seeing
so that they could reinterpret their
reality into into something that was
more functional and less Trump
derangement syndrome yeah well as I said
before I mean that's why you're good at
what you do because I listened and
that's why I wasn't crazed and that's
why I think my audience even I have no
idea which if I was appalled my entire
audience which way they voted or you
know whatever it is but I think that for
most of them they were
they didn't go off the deep end you know
to mean like they actually didn't go
crazy and they've sort of when I try to
keep my people dealing in reality which
somehow is very special these days I
didn't realize it was special but but
apparently it is yeah I I don't know how
long it will take for the people who you
know are screaming at the sky to to
affect some change but I think I think
the keys could be and I'm not predicting
that these will happen but these would
be the keys if President Trump did
something useful in North Korea they
really looked to people like oh my god
that I wasn't seeing I didn't see that
coming
and something could happen with
healthcare which by the way I think both
of them are entirely possible you know
I'm not sure what the pods are but they
seem very possible to me it would be
hard a year from now to to feel the same
way about his presidency assuming he
doesn't do any anything that's extra bad
between now and then yeah
is that also just the nature of basic
human psychology that you can only
scream for so much time like they've
really dragged this screaming out right
but you can't do that forever your brain
will explode well my mother had a saying
and I don't know where I came from she
said you can get used to anything if you
do it long enough including hanging if
you hang long enough you just get used
to it yeah and and I've predicted for a
long time that as as provocative as
President Trump is as long as you stay
provocative in the same way you will get
used to it and I think you're starting
to see that but there's certainly a big
segment of the population that is now
close to getting used to it yet yeah
what do you make of the Russia thing you
know I hate to say on camera well
there's nothing there and there's
nothing there never will be anything
there but at the moment yeah at this
conversation there's nothing that looks
like it's a crime that if that influence
that's involving the president directly
I'd be surprised if there is but you
know certainly if there is it would be
some kind of technical thing that he
that the average person says well I
didn't even know that was a
so that's what happens when you get the
SPECIAL beyond the special prosecutor in
there is there they're looking for
crimes now yeah and at a certain level
of you know money power you know
influence people are doing stuff that's
gonna violate some law or or an ethical
violation so if you look you're gonna
find stuff my guess is there's more
smoke than than fire and that the smoke
has been sort of generated by the
coverage of it yeah well every time they
keep pushing more smoke out there the
smoke actually starts looking like it
also has a lot to do with Hillary and
the DNC so it's like you all better be
very careful what you ask for here
because this could take down all you
well and then the question I ask is
Russia is sort of a weird relationship
with the United States you know there's
sort of frenemies you know we want them
on our side but they seem to be doing
stuff to to bother us but we have fairly
deep connections and have had for a long
time so there are lots of people having
lots of conversations at powerful levels
probably all the time but when you look
at them and you look at them through a
certain filter you say well now it looks
wrong whereas maybe in a different time
we would just say well yeah why wouldn't
we be talking to someone who has so many
interests that they overlap with ours
yeah that does show the way things flip
very easily now it seems like the
Democrats I mean look if you took this
thing to attack let's pretend there was
you know some legit reason for them to
be talking about Russia what are we
really saying that are we gonna depose
the President of the United States and
you can't then put pence in because he
probably knew about it so you can't have
his guy in there and then what are you
really saying should we go down the line
of succession should you know Paul Ryan
then be installed president and really
what are you saying because then if they
actually hacked our election and put the
president in office that's obviously an
act of war so are you saying we should
nuke Russia I mean that's why it seems
to me we've got you know Obama running
around the whole country doing his
$500,000 speeches which I don't begrudge
him but with that shit-eating grin and
everybody else is out there doing the
thing where if they knew that the
president was a Russian spy or colluded
it's like
maybe out in the streets screaming about
it but you know one of the things that
really strikes me is that there are
things that are alleged as you know
traitorous the illegal activities that
if you had asked me as this traitorous
or illegal I would have said doesn't
sound like it to me
for example if the Russians had some
dirt on Hillary and if they offered it
to the campaign if you had asked me
without any of this news coverage in
which we've all learned more about how
this works is it illegal to gather
information from someone who has
information I would say how is it
illegal to talk to people mm-hmm why
would it be illegal to know more if it's
true why would it be illegal to have
true information now that's an
interesting distinction though let's
pause there for a second so if the
Russian government let's say had been
falsifying information and passed it on
to the Trump campaign and then the Trump
campaign used it you would see that you
would view that differently so the
information itself has to be true right
well yes I think people would view that
differently because that would look more
like a well either way it looks like
Russia is trying to influence things but
just because they're trying to influence
things does that mean that the person
who would benefit from the information
is forbidden from having it now this is
where that you have to be a lawyer to
know whether or not that's illegal I
look at it ago okay I can get the
argument that so might be you know
unethical I can get the argument that we
shouldn't do it I can get the argument
that Russia shouldn't be meddling and we
need to we need to respond in some way
but how is it illegal for a person to
hear information yeah in what world does
the source of the information matter if
it's actual information well that's why
it's funny you saw when when what was
about a month and a half ago when Trump
jr. the whole week was that Trump jr.
met with the person who may have gotten
some information from the Russians or
whatever it was and everyone was
screaming about you know you get
opposition research but not from other
countries blah blah blah and then just
in the last couple weeks it came out
that for sure the DNC was you know at
least working at some level with either
this Ukrainian guy or the Russians to
make the dossier I mean just looks like
we don't even have to go into all of it
it's just like you're all dirty you're
all eteri yeah and and it's it's such a
confusing area that the the public
doesn't have any idea what's going on
down with Russia we know there's
something about Russia
something about lawyers you know and and
if you were to ask the average person
I'm you've probably seen these street
interviews where somebody goes out and
says name the Vice President of the
United States and they're like Mickey
Mouse you know they have no idea right
imagine going out in the street just
grabbing a person say can you sort out
the Russia thing for me can you tell me
who did what they're gonna tell you that
there's something about a Russian lawyer
who put uranium on a hotel bed you know
it's it's gonna be this but this mess of
stuff that they've conflated in their
minds the public has no idea what's
going on yeah how do you figure out what
news you believe and what you think is
true and what you can actually trust oh
you I think every situation you get a
look at it differently so the first the
first sort if I see it on either Fox or
I see it on CNN the first thing I do is
go to the other one because do you have
two TVs next to each other well I've got
a clicker and and I wait because it's
not gonna be at the same time
necessarily but I wait because my
experience is that for on a factual
basis they all pretty much get the facts
right it's it's the interpretation it's
the priority it's how much attention
they put it's which pundits come on and
say what about it that that is where all
the the bias happens so the first thing
is do they both say it and if they do I
start feeling comfortable that maybe
there's there's some truth to it but
then all the spin comes and almost all
of that is you know non-factual spin so
I kind of discount all of that from both
sides yeah do you think anyone's due in
the persuasion game correctly on the
other side so whoever might be your
intellectual opponent that buys into all
of the things say of the modern
Democratic Party is there anyone that's
kind of doing it right um even if you
disagree with all of the conclusions or
what they're trying to build
yeah let me say something that I know
makes you could make at least half of
your listeners just flip out George
Clooney has game alright now I don't
think he can run because the whole
Hollywood Weinstein connection but yeah
in a recent interview I saw I saw so
much technique that I didn't know he had
that much technique and he basically was
setting himself up that if people begged
he would he would run now I don't know
if you would agree cuz once they did
some polling they might find out he has
some issues but he has the charisma and
he has the persuasion game that if he
could bring a little bit of substance he
would actually be quite formidable I
don't think he can be Trump well he
could probably really take a run as
someone else you know a regular
Republican likewise Mark Cuban he's
definitely making some noise in this
space right right now he did an
interesting thing by saying that you
know he could potentially be either a
Republican or a Democrat which was kind
of clever because it allows both both
groups to see him until he commits as
well maybe one of mine you know but I
think it let somebody said that he said
he would maybe run his Republican but
the Republicans have a long memory
there's no way there's no way he gets
elected as a Republican but could he be
elected as a Democrat if he brought in
some ideas involved technology for
example there would maybe get us to
better health care a way to get to free
college because that's the part that
Bernie was missing he had everything
right except the connecting tissues like
how do you get there that you could
afford it technology could probably get
there or at least you could make a story
that I could get there and I think it
would be believable because because I
think because I think we can I think
cubed could could make that story I
think he's got the charisma he's got the
brains you might be able to pull it off
but I don't know if he'll run this
Democrat so so not that I have any love
of sort of career politicians or people
that have just been around politics a
lot but it's interesting you just went
basically to all celebrities even Cuban
in effect really is
celebrity at this point why wouldn't
charisma if there had been any standard
politician with charisma
I would probably gravitate to him via
Van Jones is very good yeah he would be
high in my list of charismatic Democrat
he agreed to do this show and then CNN
wouldn't let him do it
so really uh so I don't know why I don't
know where that puts my feelings about
him or at least he said he would do it
on Twitter and then they said no so
maybe he was just playing me it sort of
you know sort of the public cred of yeah
I'll do it and then leave it to my guys
who will just say no I don't know the
details but I find him incredible
credible was starting with his safe yeah
my guess is they told you the truth yeah
so if we can't have sort of regular
politicians anymore because that's
really whether they're celebrities or
just because you're saying these people
don't exist in the world it seems that
the long-term health of the system it
doesn't strike me as that great in that
case that we're just gonna keep living
in a world where facts don't matter
we're gonna keep sort of putting
persuasion sort of ahead of we've always
been in that world it's not a new world
it's just that we we have a character in
the president right now who takes it to
a level where you can't miss it
mmm I think before you had the luxury of
saying well my side is telling the truth
right but we don't even have that luxury
anymore like you even if you're a pro
Trump you know that the fact checkers
are not wrong every time right you just
don't think it matters because he's
persuading in the direction that you
like all right well to put a nice bow
then on this whole conversation since
you've done a nice job I think
persuading people in general but I
upfront admit you've helped persuade me
in certain ways I want some predictions
out of you Adams where is this all going
does this guy run again in what would be
about three years now does he step aside
do the Democrats finally wake up to some
of this stuff lay it out give me
something here I think you're going to
see you something good with health care
maybe by the summer I think that the
economy will stay strong unless there's
some surprise that we we haven't seen
but straight line it looks like it's
going to stay strong
I think we'll hit four percent GDP I
think that at the end of Trump's four
years unless something new happens it's
gonna look really successful and if he's
smart he will at least consider going
out on top
especially because age becomes a little
bit more of an issue at that point
mm-hmm and for a brand or someone who
would like to go out and say okay you
know I also have a company with my name
on it
it might make sense to go out on top but
he's also a really competitive guy yeah
and so he might just want to take it to
the next level but I'm not sure that I'm
rooting for that because I think age has
to matter in that job yeah and I suspect
that even if everything you predict
there is true and everything's going
great and it looks like he could win
again
I do think you know this is the guy who
made the apprentice and that it would be
like he would just anoint his successor
and then that person would have to do
the job whether it's Don junior or
whoever else it is but that he would
then step off as the king and you know
not even risk he already pulled off one
major coup so to speak and not even risk
the second one yeah it's gonna be
tempting to to keep the brand you know
clean if he has a great four years and
just go out with that yeah all right
well it's always a pleasure talking to
you I feel that we should do this you
know probably a little more than maybe
once a year so and that way I can keep
grading your predictions is anyone
tracking you is there a blog devoted to
Adam said this he got this one wrong got
this one I think everyone should be they
should drop what they're doing it just
tracked my predictions well I have them
in my book win big Lee yeah so you can
you can see them there yeah I will put
the Amazon link right down below yeah
it's a pleasure as always thank you so
much and for more on Scott Adams you can
follow him on the Twitter where he does
a lot of morning periscopes with you do
you always have the coffee before you
start I could never talk to people
without the first set I always have
coffee before I talk to humans yes it's
a good good strategy that is a true
persuasive technique that you all should
be taking into account and it is Scott
Adam says on the Twitter
[Music]
you